just ask you about some possible
criticisms of bitcoin
so on centralization so
there's a criticism on the so on the
mining and on the node side uh or the
node is not really the criticism but
bitcoin mining is not fully
decentralized because a small number of
miners uh control a majority of the
hashing power
i looked it up as ten thousand fifteen
thousand whatever the number is of of
computers they have the full their full
nodes that have the full
uh that are actively connected to the
network so you could argue that's
decentralized because it's global it's
all across the world but the miners
they're still
um
it's more centralized so if you're
thinking of making a case for bitcoin
being decentralized
do you worry about the miners
being somewhat centralized is is the
nodes the important thing to think about
yeah and what number of nodes counts are
centralized and not
the nodes are what matters because the
nodes are what uh determines bitcoin's
consensus parameters i think the the um
the the best way to think about it is
that miners simply sell a commodity to
the nodes and that commodity is bitcoin
blocks so what a miner does is they
solve the proof-of-work problem so they
keep operating their computers until
they can get a solution to the problem
and then they attach that to a bunch of
transactions and present it to the nodes
for the nodes to ratify and approve it
so therefore uh this is
and this is i i strongly recommend
people learn about the 2017 lock size
war to understand
why miners don't control bitcoin i
discussed this uh briefly in my uh
bitcoin standard but there's a recent
book that discusses this in detail
called the block size war by jonathan
beer it's a great description of
in 2017 essentially the miners thought
that they could control bitcoin you know
they had there was uh one mining company
that uh produced the majority of the
machines that were on the network and
they
and their allies had a control of the
machines that were out there
and they controlled the majority of the
hash rate and they thought that they
could change bitcoin's
supply not supply sorry they could
change bitcoin's block size which is a
tiny little detail technical parameter
it's not even
all that big of a deal for the economics
of it but they thought that they could
pass
this change they could force this change
on the network
and the members of the network
rejected it and they weren't able to do
it so the nodes are what is sovereign
the nodes are what determine the rules
of the game
the miners
are a service provider the miners invest
capital up front you know they buy the
machines they buy the electricity they
buy these storage they buy the locations
they pay the rent
and they invest all of that money
based on the idea that if they behave
according to what the nodes want the
nodes will reward them with bitcoin so
the miners are in no position to dictate
terms for anyone you know they've
they've put up their capital up front
and they will only recoup it if they do
what the nodes want
so therefore what really matters is the
decentralization of the nodes so we want
to we you want to have as many nodes as
possible you should um you want to have
a system where there's a large number of
nodes and this is of course the biggest
problem with um
with other digital currencies is that
you know because basically bitcoin has
cornered the market on a digital
currency the only way that you can
really get traction um is to generate a
whole bunch of buzzwords but you know
we're doing this and we're doing that
and so
other digital currencies are optimized
for um
bells and whistles and buzzwords
and that means adding a computational
load which makes the nodes bigger harder
to operate and therefore you have a very
small number of nodes in fact
very few digital currencies are
keen to publicize how many nodes there
are and they don't have full nodes in
the true sense and it doesn't even
matter how many nodes they have because
um
de facto you know you can you can spin
up a million nodes tomorrow on aws
doesn't really matter
what matters is de facto do the nodes
dictate the rules of consensus and the
fact that with most digital currencies
you can have hard forks very frequently
and they can change the supply all the
time
means that there's a small group of
people who agree amongst themselves how
to move forward yeah so
you threw in a few criticisms of all
coins there but so one is the small
group
that one would we could talk about it's
a tricky one and we we talked about that
with satoshi nakamoto but the other one
is a
small number of nodes so to push back on
that as computational power increases
you can argue that
that enables more and more uh cheap
computers to serve as nodes so at least
it paints the future where nodes are
always increasing because computational
power is always increasing and getting
cheaper and cheaper and cheaper so at
least there's a hope for the future for
greater and greater decentralization
decentralization on the node front
yeah but i mean
ultimately again it doesn't really
matter how many nodes uh you have if you
have a you know
if the way that the currency is run is
that you're going to have a hard fork
every few months which is the case with
most other currencies bitcoin is the
only one that's not have a hard fork
um basically the the unique thing about
bitcoin uh in a tactical sense is that
you could get the original software that
satoshi himself ran
in 2009 to start the network
and you could run it today
and it would sync with the blockchain
there's one bug you need to fix
uh one mistake that was owned that would
have only appeared i think in around
2013 or 14 or something like that
that he wasn't aware of back then so you
just need to fix this one tiny little
bug and then the consensus parameters
are still the same so you're able to
sync to it
this is not true for most other digital
currencies i'd say probably all of them
because they've all had many hard forks
which they think of as upgrades and you
know they they market this thing as you
know well bitcoin can't upgrade but we
upgrade all the time well yeah you know
what else upgrades all the time um
facebook apple amazon anything that
centralizes very easy to upgrade and
that's precisely why as michael saylor
says these things are somebody's
liability their security you're carrying
on somebody's technical and economic
liability they can
hard fork they can 10x the supply
tomorrow yeah
they can fall victim to the same
[Music]
um corrupting forces that governments
fall victim to sure and for people who
don't know yeah hard fork
is a
reverse incompatible change to uh
to the underlying function of a
cryptocurrency
of course there is hard forks of
uh bitcoin as well
i'm sure all of which you love
dearly anyway but that doesn't that
doesn't matter the original bitcoin uh
for the most part has has not undergone
any changes
and that's one of the i mean it has
undergone changes but none
none in the uh important parameters of
the network
you